le problème maintenant c'est les miss
france c'est comme les présidents de la
république l'état de grâce ne dure pas
il ya immédiatement des politiques sur
miss france alors c'est toujours les
mêmes aux arguments c'est un peu un
marronnier les mêmes arguments qui
reviennent c'est un concours sexistes
c'est un peu ringard c'est un peu désuet
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça c'est
un point de vue qu'il appartient en ce
qui me concerne et si j'ai décidé de le
faire c'est parce que je ne partage pas
je suis très très heureuse d'avoir pu
prendre part à sa et et c'est vraiment
enrichi au maximum que je me présente
aujourd'hui face à vous pouvez aborder
la suite de ma vie enora malagré
représentante du camp de ce cri de ceux
qui n'aiment pas le concours de miss
france 14 heures du mans énorme mais ils
sont assez pauvres
d'habitude je t'ai pas bien vendu voilà
non mais c'est vrai que pour moi c'est
un combat pour agricole de la femme
c'est à dire que pour moi c'est vraiment
qui a la plus belle croupe qui a les
plus beaux yeux les plus fâcheuses je
trouve que c'est extrêmement sexy c'est
extrêmement réducteur pour les femmes au
delà du fait que tout ce qui est robes à
paillettes limite patinage artistique
soit pour moi ou du dollar de la
ringardise mais ça c'est ça c'est
l'écrin ça c'est autre chose et c'est
vrai que j'ai du mal à comprendre en
tant que femme qu'on puisse accepter de
se faire juger uniquement que sur son
apparence
cela dit vous vous sort vous avez bien
sorti votre épingle du jeu puisque on
vous a reproché d'être trop ronde
je trouve que alors je pense pas que ce
soit très conscient mais vous avez porté
un peu le drapeau dans une forme de body
positivisme a comme on dit que vous avez
au final assez bien mené je trouve
parce que vous êtes ce que vous répondez
à savoir déjà je dis merci parce que
c'est cool a dit qu'elle aime pas mais
quand même pas trop mal quand même dans
ses divers angles de la beauté l'ema
mais sous l'angle des grosses elles
adorent
mais c'est quand même année
c'est le résumé qui est pas tout à fait
un infidèle mais qui est légèrement par
shia loire alors déjà c'est vrai qu'il
ya 30 candidates qui skie qui auparavant
étaient sélectionnés à une élection
régionale
et ça ça dépend vraiment des des comités
qui choisissent parce que par exemple
nous à tahiti on a d'abord un grand oral
qui détermine 50% du résultat final au
cours duquel on aborde des sujets
d'actualité on aborde des sujets sociaux
on peut parler de tout et de n'importe
quoi il faut avoir une argumentation qui
soit quand même eu percutante pour qu'on
puisse être retenu parmi les finalistes
et puis et puis après effectivement on
est jugé sur la beauté après
pardonnez-moi mais aucune d'entre vous à
mon sens a encore été très percutante on
est loin du discours par exemple de la
messieurs univers la queue qui a été lu
il ya assez peu qu'ils étaient vraiment
un discours à mon sens assez porteur et
féministe trouve qu' aucune d'entre vous
que ça soit vos prédécesseurs trice
super je fais une belle rentrée sur tu
vas pas être pris aux prochaines mises à
tromper le cerveau dont et du coup je
trouve que justement vous n'en fait pas
grand chose de cette élection soit vous
comme je vous ai dit je vous ai fait un
compliment mais c'était un peu malgré
vous ce que vous avez subi un peu la
foudre des de la twittosphère mais
c'était un peu malgré vous et je trouve
que vous n'en fait pas grand chose
quelque part on peut pas vraiment se
positionner parce qu'on doit rester
neutre pour éviter peut-être le
d'offenser certains personnels dommage
d'être neutre quand on a effectivement
un tel pouvoir entre les mains je trouve
ça un petit peu dommage d'être à ce
point fadasse je viens vous êtes dans
quelques mois si dans un an je suis dans
un camp très simple j'adore regarder
passer les filles dans la rue pourquoi
je n'aimerais pas les voir défiler sur
une estrade je suis pas contre le
concours c'est un concours de beauté
après tout les emplois de de participer
au concours de beauté c'est plus l'écrin
qui mériteraient dans les petites
épreuves d'être un peu à peu des
derniers voilà c'est sûr désuet
j'aime bien les choses depuis quelques
années ça il faut l'admettre
oui font des efforts mais ça reste un
peu ringard mais ça c'est pas de votre
faute